robert spencer the biden administration
is seeking to restore the
jcpoa the joint comprehensive plan of
action
which was obama's iran nuclear deal and
it's now the
biden nuclear deal and get this
john bolton former national security
adviser says no
idea meaning washington has no idea how
flawed this deal is
they don't like to say it publicly it
rests on the assumption if they can just
give the ayatollahs what they want
they'll calm down and that will convince
them they don't have to worry about the
united states and israel
according to biden i'm sorry according
to bolton it's a fantasy and it's a
dangerous fantasy
is bolton correct uh i
i have to say i'm no fan of john bolton
but it is true that he's absolutely
right about this
uh the iranian nuclear deal is just what
donald trump said it was
the worst agreement that any american
president
has ever entered into in any context
because
the nuclear deal is supposed to limit
iran's
capability of developing nuclear weapons
but the reality is
that it gives permission to the iranians
actually to inspect their own
nuclear sites and report back on their
own compliance
under some circumstances and when it
does allow for
outside inspectors they have to give
three weeks notice before they come in
and so that's plenty of time for the
iranians to
hide everything that might arouse
suspicion
in the meantime you've got the genocidal
rhetoric coming out of the islamic
republic
and the fact that everything in the
joint comprehensive plan of action
expires within 10 years
which is now four years from now and
that
would mean that after that there is
absolutely no restriction upon iran's
nuclear program
the whole thing was really the obama
administration's kicking the football
down the road
so that some later administration was
going to have to deal with a nuclear
weapon with
within iran with nuclear weapons
you